au milieu de la mégalopole parisienne
des agents du conseil départemental
sillonnent chaque jour la ville marc is
it se rend dans l'un des centres
d'accueil conventionné par la
collectivité on arrose et rouge
un centre d'hébergement pour
accompagnement de personnes malades à
vendre des accompagnants ils viennent
ici déjà pour pour dormir normalement
pour manger et pendant que leurs enfants
se fassent soigner dans les hôpitaux et
en même temps ici ils ont désactivé qui
permet de candidat pendant les temps ils
sont libres ils peuvent sauter comme
enfin se distraire bonjour alors ça va
et j'ai pourtant madame omar est à paris
pour accompagner son fils kelyan opérer
des oreilles à l'hôpital necker pour
l'opération de mon fils il a une
choriste collecter atom c'est à dire
qu'une otites à répétition sans douleur
donc à la réunion pourrait plus faire il
ya un cerf les médecins l'ont transféré
ici en france en isère pour être opéré
j'ai connu ça passe tant social de ma
ville le département la ville à sa prose
elle m'a expliqué qu'elle va faire le
lien de la réunion fait le lien avec
département cette démarche est possible
pour tout accompagnateurs qui
remplissent certaines conditions pour le
séjour d'appréhension particulière
il va dans le dans un but ou dans une
maison départementale constituer un
dossier dans lequel il va demander une
aide spécifique en fait en fonction de
ce qui a besoin dossier nous est
transmis et quand il arriva en métropole
en
on va le chercher quand je faisais un
aéroport est on là qu'on accompagne
pendant tout son séjour chez mango
double lincoln lawyer sans permis avec
maman dommage vraiment dommage
oui ne vois vous le tour eiffel c'est
pour vous remettre également le pack
vous avez parlé quand vous avez appelé
que vous auriez droit un puck sans cris
telle ressource la sueur et dans le pack
la voix de téléphone auquel il avait
droit à un téléphone portable numéro il
ya une recharge
ensuite vous allez droit également à des
tickets de métro voilà le ticket de
métro pour vous dépanner une dizaine un
plan de paris avec des différents métro
en 2011 et tout ça meurt et ça on va
vous donne est simple pour poser une
coordonnée le numéro vert est numéro 2
de l'antenne on appelle devenir si la
france déjà pour moi personnellement
matériel elle a connu parce qu'on ne
connaît rien c'est la première fois mais
tu es oublier obligé de venir dans
l'éducation pour monfils
donc il fallait l'accompagné on n'a pas
pu te point de chute
on n'a rien la famille très loin
financièrement riant je n'avais rien
rien et comme on avait bien expliqué on
arrivait en sibérie finances j'avais le
département m'a beaucoup aidé beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup parce que quand
j'étais à necker j'avais que les dés
pour dormir
derrière ce dispositif de la
collectivité départementale un élément
est central
kélian a eu sa maman à ses côtés pendant
cette période douloureuse de sa jeune
vie d'enfant la laideur la salle de
billard et nous peut regarder films des
fois ya les films ici et ce via c'est
que sont bizarres le stylet et qu'il y
était associé de bain que je me suis
amusé grâce à l'antenne des paris avoue
carrément nue pour les jours
non mais j'ai des tickets de métro pour
aller me balader et pouvoir aller au
rendez vous d'accord mais tu es déjà
signé oui ça c'était pas trop dur et
après ah oui comment tu as vécu les
choses bien bien parce que la présence
de ta maman c'est ça a changé dit bas
ça m'a aidé appelez surmonter ma peur de
l'opération
ça se passait mal ça s'était passé
oui oui bon toujours été là quelquefois
c'est compliqué parce que vous venez de
la réunion à 10 micromètres n'avais
personne
la malade ya un malade c'est je veux
dire la personne arrive déjà avec
beaucoup de souffrance
donc il faut vraiment les accompagner
les écouter au mieux et les aider tous
les jours qu'on en fait et c'est pour ça
qu'elle numéros verts sont lesquels ils
peuvent appeler avec un téléphone fixe
ou un gsm gratuitement 300 qu'un agent
ici une écoute et l'aide dans ses
démarches
quand on voit ça la musique l'action en
dix ans oui franchement oui parce qu'il
ya quand même sourire de gamin et à un
mot qui rassure et franchement oui pour
moi c'est quelque chose de formidable
toute l'année des agents de l'antenne de
paris accompagne les réunionnais
socialement difficultés de quoi
supporter un peu les obstacles de la vie